[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic
peut-on aller plus vite que la lumière
on entend souvent dire que l'expansion
de l'univers accélère certains objets
plus rapidement que la lumière
effectivement certains objets voit la
distance qui les sépare augmenté plus
rapidement que la vitesse de la lumière
mais cela est dû à l'expansion de
l'espace lui-même c'est-à-dire la grille
sous jacentes sur laquelle se situent
les objets cette grille est en constante
expansion et c'est elle qui fait
augmenter la distance entre les astres
cette augmentation de distance n'est pas
réellement un déplacement en particulier
cela ne permet pas d'envoyer une
information plus rapidement que la
lumière
mais à part l'expansion de l'espace lui
même est il donc possible qu'un objet se
déplacent à l'intérieur de l'espace plus
rapidement que la lumière
la théorie de la relativité restreinte
permet de comprendre que la vitesse à
laquelle se déplace un objet dans
l'espace modifie la façon dont c'est
cool sont en plus ils se déplacent
rapidement plus son temps propre ralenti
et s'écoule lentement par rapport à
l'environnement
s'il transporte une horloge les
aiguilles de cette horloge prennent
alors plus de temps pour faire un tour
complet que celle d'une horloge immobile
dans son entourage
ainsi plus un objet se déplacent
rapidement dans l'espace plus ils se
déplacent lentement dans le temps pour
quantifier la situation on peut essayer
de tracer un graphique très simple qui
représente l'écoulement du temps par
rapport à la vitesse de l'objet pour un
objet immobile de vitesse 0 le temps ne
s'écoule à 100% de son rythme normal
d'autre part pour un objet qui se
déplacerait à 100 % de la vitesse de la
lumière
le temps ne s'écoule aurait tout
simplement plus l'écoulement du temps
est alors de zéro on peut naturellement
pensé que si le temps ralenti jusqu'à
s'arrêter lorsqu'on atteint la vitesse
de la lumière il serait peut-être
possible de remonter dans le temps si
l'on pouvait se déplacer encore plus
vite plus on irait au delà de la vitesse
de la lumière plus on remonte très
rapidement dans le passé avec un
écoulement du temps qui serait négatif
c'est une idée qui semble à première vue
plausible et même très attractive
cependant elle se base sur une hypothèse
très forte que l'on a postulé sans le
préciser
c'est le fait d'avoir relié et prolonger
les deux points par une ligne droite il
existe bel et bien une certaine courbe
qui relie ces deux points et sur
laquelle se situe tout objet de
l'univers n'importe quelle forme de
matière
n'importe quel objet se trouve sur cette
courbe est dès lors qu'ils se déplacent
à une certaine vitesse sont en propre
s'écoule forcément un rythme qui est
bien déterminé en quelque sorte le temps
ralentit de la même façon pour tous les
corps dès lors qu'ils ont la même
vitesse mais lorsqu'on réalise
l'expérience pour déterminer si cette
courbe est bien une ligne droite on
mesure qu'un corps qui se déplace à 50 %
de la vitesse de la lumière voit son
temps s'écoule et non pas à 50% mais
environ 87% de son rythme normal
de même un corps qui se déplace à 80 %
de la vitesse de la lumière voit son
temps propre s'écouler à 60% et un corps
se déplaçant à 25 % de la vitesse de la
lumière ne perçoit presque pas de
différence avec une immobilité
car son temps s'écoule toujours à près
de 97% du rythme normal
la courbe qui se dessine alors sous nos
yeux n'est pas une ligne droite mais
plutôt un quart de cercle
toute la matière contenues dans
l'univers se situe quelque part sur ce
quart de cercle comme notre ligne droite
précédemment cette courbe peut être
prolongée en un cercle complet à gauche
du graphique
les vitesses négative correspondent tout
simplement à des vitesses quand on se
déplace dans le sens opposé
s'ils se déplaçait vers la droite donne
une vitesse positives par exemple un
kilomètre par heure alors se déplacer
avec une vitesse négative de - 1 km par
heure revient seulement à se déplacer
avec cette vitesse vers la gauche
pour commencer on remarque qu'il n'est
jamais possible ni de dépasser la
vitesse de la lumière ni de dépasser une
vitesse temporel de 100%
en effet même pour un objet hypothétique
qui remonteraient dans le temps
c'est à dire avec un écoulement temporel
négatif il serait strictement impossible
de dépasser la vitesse de la lumière car
tout objet est confiné sur ce cercle
la question intéressante n'est donc plus
de savoir s'il est possible de dépasser
la vitesse de la lumière mais plutôt
d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi une
telle chose est impossible
pourquoi la courbe prend une forme de
cercle est ce qu'il ya de si particulier
avec la vitesse de la lumière
commençons par nous pencher sur la forme
bien particulière de cette courbe un
cercle
la particularité d'un cercle et que tous
les points qui le composent se trouve à
la même distance du centre pour un objet
quelconque la quantité qui a réellement
du sens ce n'est ni sa vitesse dans
l'espace ni le rythme d'écoulement de
son temps mais plutôt sa distance depuis
le centre du graphique
cette quantité prend en compte à la fois
le déplacement de l'objet dans l'espace
et son déplacement dans le temps il
s'agit en fait là d'une unification des
deux vitesses ou mélange à la fois la
vitesse de l'objet dans l'espace et dans
le temps
c'est sa vitesse dans l'espace temps
quelle que soit la vitesse d'un objet
même s'ils accélèrent au ralenti sa
position dans le graphique va changer
mais sa distance au centre va toujours
rester la même cette quantité est une
constante fondamental universel qui
régit absolument tous les corps de
l'univers c'est cette quantité qu'on
appelle la vitesse de la lumière il est
important de comprendre que la vitesse
de la lumière est quelque chose de
fondamental elle n'est pas importante
parce que la lumière se déplace avec
cette vitesse
elle est importante parce que dans
l'espace temps quand on prend en compte
l espace et le temps c'est la vitesse à
laquelle se déplacent absolument tous
les objets
avec cette idée en tête
on comprend mieux le phénomène qui est à
l'oeuvre les objets ne peuvent pas
dépasser la vitesse de la lumière
tout simplement parce qu'il se déplace
toujours avec exactement cette vitesse
la seule marge de liberté que peut avoir
un corps et lorsqu'il distribue cette
vitesse entre l'espace et le temps
si l'objet est plutôt en haut du
graphique
il donne beaucoup de vitesse au temps et
peu de vitesse à l'espace son temps
s'écoule presque normalement
mais il ne se déplace pas très vite dans
l'espace cela correspond au comportement
des objets de notre quotidien qui sont
immobiles par rapport à nous ou du moins
relativement lent quand on les compare à
la vitesse de la lumière
d'autre part si un objet se situe plutôt
en bas à droite du graphique
il donne davantage de vitesse à l'espace
qu'autant les objets les plus rapides de
l'univers se déplace très vite dans
l'espace mais par conséquent très
lentement dans le temps il évolue au
ralenti par rapport à nous cela
correspond en particulier à la lumière
qui est le cas extrême où toute la
vitesse est donné uniquement à l'espace
une particules de lumière se déplacent
extrêmement vite
mais son temps ne s'écoule alors plus du
tout si elle portait une horloge
imaginaire ses aiguilles resterait
immobile un objet qui accélère
n'augmente pas sa vitesse il va
seulement la convertir d'une vitesse
temporel qui le fait progresser dans le
temps en une vitesse spatiale qui le
fait avancer dans l'espace
et vice versa un objet qui va ralentir
converti une partie de sa vitesse
spatiale en vitesse temporel globalement
sa vitesse dans l'espace-temps est
restée constante
il se déplace toujours à la vitesse de
la lumière c'est seulement la
répartition de cette vitesse entre temps
et espace qui a été modifié pour finir
cette représentation sous la forme d'un
graphique a beaucoup davantage car elle
est très visuel et permet de donner une
intuition très forte de certains
phénomènes
par exemple on peut se demander s'il
existe des objets qui se situe sur la
partie basse du graphique
intuitivement de tels objets devraient
remonter dans le temps car leur vitesse
temporel serait négative
et effectivement on peut dans un certain
cadre interpréter qu'il existe bel et
bien un type de particules dans
l'univers qui se situe dans cette partie
du diagramme c'est ce qu'on appelle
communément l'antimatière les particules
d'antimatière ont les mêmes propriétés
que les particules normal si ce n'est
que leur charge électrique est opposé
elles sont en quelque sorte les
symétrique des particules ordinaire la
partie haute du graphique est la partie
où se trouve la matière ordinaire tandis
que la partie basse sont symétriques et
le monde de l'anti matière
les particules de lumière quant à elle
les photons sont leurs propres
symétrique
car elle se trouve à l'extrême droite du
diagramme le photon est donc sa propre
antiparticules
enfin il faut quand même prendre
quelques précautions car toute cette
représentation n'est basée que sur le
modèle de la relativité restreinte
modèle keane est exact que dans le cas
d'un univers vide parfaitement plat dans
la réalité notre univers n'est pas plat
il est parsemé d'étoilés et de planètes
qui déforme en quatre dimensions la
géométrie de l'espace temps et il faut
alors utiliser la relativité générale en
relativité générale la gravité n'existe
pas c'est seulement la courbure de
l'espace temps qui va naturellement
convertir la vitesse temporelle des
objets en vitesse spatiale si une pomme
tombe d'un arbre alors qu'elles étaient
au départ
immobile c'est parce que son écoulement
dans le temps a été progressivement
converti en vitesse vers le bas et ce
par la courbure spatio-temporelle
engendrés par la masse de la terre
si on observe de loin un objet qui se
trouve à côté d'un corps massif comme la
terre le graphique qui lui est associé
valeur se déformer à proximité d'un trou
noir notamment le cercle se déforme
tellement qu'il se réduit de plus en
plus au fur et à mesure que l'objet sera
proche de l'horizon
lorsqu'il finit par atteindre l'horizon
des événements
le cercle est alors entièrement
contracter ce qui signifie que l'objet
n'a alors plus aucune marge d'évolution
de notre point de vue il reste figé
immobile à la surface du trou noir
lorsqu'on les observe depuis un endroit
éloigné
tous les objets qui tombe dans un trou
noir finissent par se figer à sa surface
pour un tel objet ce phénomène n'est
qu'une illusion pour lui il est tout à
fait possible de traverser l'horizon du
trou noir
il continue progressivement sa chute
vers la singularité centrale mais pour
nous en tant qu'observateur qui
regardons la situation depuis
l'extérieur toutes les informations
qu'ils décrivent cet objet ralentissent
progressivement jusqu'à s'arrêter pour
rester finalement figé à la surface du
trou noir
l'une des conséquences les plus
importantes de ce phénomène et que
l'entropie d'un trou noir
c'est à dire en quelque sorte son
information et sa température est
entièrement décrite est distribué à sa
surface
[Musique]